Speaker 1: One other little thing here on
the Alex Jones verdict.
A Roger Stone started desperately pleading
for money for Alex Jones after the $49 million
verdict.
This was actually within I think it was within
within minutes.
Roger Stone went on Infowars to make an urgent
plea.
Send Alex Jones money.
He needs the money or this verdict may sink
Infowars.
Here's here's Roger Stone.
Speaker 3: Alex Jones is a good and decent
man.
He's a God fearing Christian, and he's done
more for this movement than perhaps anyone
you can name.
And right now, he needs our support.
There's a place at the Infowars store we can
go just to make a contribution.
If you're not in the market for a book or
one of his great products, there's a link
where you can just send a Yeah.
Speaker 1: You can just send money, folks.
It's that simple.
So, listen, at some point, there has to be
some kind of buyer beware thing.
Okay.
We talked about this in the context of after
the 2020 election, Donald Trump started asking
for money and he claimed that the reason he
was asking for money was that he was going
to fund audits and he was going to overturn
results and file lawsuits and all these different
things.
And it actually said in the fine print, hey,
you know, $0.50 on the dollar or in some cases
even more than that actually goes to paying
off Trump campaign debt or into the coffers
or however whatever the language was that
they were using there.
And then people donated.
And there was one rich guy who donated, I
don't remember if it was 200,000 or $2 million.
And then he sued and he wanted the money back.
He said he got scammed then.
I don't even know what the outcome of the
case was at this point.
If after all this you go and you donate to
Alex Jones now at some point you've got Absol
right as out of luck, if you understand what
I'm saying at some point.
I mean, if you even just go to his website
and you see the stuff that's being sold seeds,
centers and survival accessories and various
brain food and strange stuff, at a certain
point, when you see that legally, the stuff
Alex Jones says is wrong and defamatory, even
if you believe the system is against him or
whatever.
Wouldn't you have to be smart enough to realize
that if that's the case, maybe it doesn't
make sense for you to be donating money.
Maybe you don't have to be part of the cause
of paying this $49 million settlement.
Now, the other thing I think that bears repeating
is the following.
In Texas, there are limits to damages, and
so the award may get dramatically reduced.
Imagine if the award gets reduced to 5 million
and Alex Jones raises 20 because people think
he really has to pay 49 and then he just keeps
the cash.
I mean, it's not when your fan base is the
people in the Alex Jones fan base.
It's not completely beyond me that Alex Jones
might be able to turn this into a moneymaking
endeavor.
I'm not saying I'm confident that will happen,
but it's not completely inconceivable.
Unbelievable stuff.
We all have a responsibility when we're on
the air.
And I actually think about what I'm saying
and when I make a mistake, I make every effort
to correct it.
And I don't target private citizens and all
these different things.
There have to be some limits.
And it seems as though Alex Jones has come
up against those limits.